bien
imagina insatisfecha
[Música]
silencio de muerte
la demás gente saber que tienes una
discapacidad y te describe como una
persona que era absurda e insignificante
cuando en definitiva no es así
esta fue la habitual 25 años como tim
existía
[Música]
y asia sindicalistas
estas nuevas tras la historia de mi
hermano simplemente las personas como
ella visual motora sensorial múltiple
quizás nunca conoceríamos describir
instante empieza en el exterior sigue
las gradas los comentarios básculas y
los dos
para mi hermana los activos y los casos
de los grupos son separados por ser
diferentes cuando hacía una escuela
esperando que el unión con la niña
capacidad de lo que muchos utilicen
opinión no debería ser empleado las
primarias cuesta que darles no hay
maestros preparados para una persona
miente o puede aprender lo mismo que los
demás y que física e intelectualmente es
más lenta
y debido a estos momentos de
discriminación de mi hermana yo me
percaté de todo el día con día así que
me dije oye la que está haciendo tal
permanece navigon variando su
preparación al área para no ser mejor
programas y me disfruta que esta
pregunta no sólo para 112
crecí y profundo la ciencia y la
tecnología en el diseño de proyectos de
estas áreas y así es cómo participar en
esta tulares de impotencias nacionales e
internacional es decir tecnología e
innovación llamada muchas de ellas
pero la verdad es que para mejorar la
vida de la sociedad
las personas
participarán de amplias y 200 así más
encontrados de recuerdos que sigan
buscando si no te conformes y que así
como todas las cosas que quieres de
verdad
sabrás cuando ellas sin controlar porque
diez más
[Música]
incluso
pero es fundamental la ciencia la
ciencia nuestras personas quintana
explicó
al ser humano sin saber nuestras penas
está la complicidad del ser humano
esta es la verdadera ciencia de ser
humano se pregunta si son más del 100 a
200 años
[Música]
no ha servido para nada
pero después
las francesas que me permitieron
completar a ciencia es una forma de
pensar
y desde esa experiencia en la secundaria
está prendida de pensar que sería y
empecé a responde por ellas comencé a
aprender a hacer con él estamos todos
los días aquí fue una competencia de
programación innovación centres de
ciencia tecnología y poesía identificar
los momentos que los teniendo más
riesgos y en los que tienen la
motivación entusiasmo y práctica así que
quiere saber cómo ha sido hasta ahora
con esos elementos lo puedes hacer
y cuando estaba en mi vida él quería ser
sumamente difícil porque soñaba para
hacer muchas cosas a nuevas es una
estudiar y emprender
porque también iglesias viniese y tal
vez es tradicionalmente difícil así que
tenés que pasar con múltiples puros
aceptar que podrás repasar los
prosistema tienes fiel otras cosas poner
sumamente difíciles puedes volver a
empezar con una y otra vez y dicho por
eso para ser feliz y lograr pánico
increíble
saber esto proceso en el pérdida hacia
la área para trabajar en la universidad
ya que en definitiva extraño todos
juntos filipinas secundarias a todas las
personas conocí pero por eso te decía
más salió tienes una mera pasión por
algo puede ser posible para lograrlo si
tienes que esforzarte tanto más
desalentando como puedas y parcial de
las molestias
las lazos dormir y las preguntas de la
gente porque lo haces
básicamente tracción paso a la vez las
cosas toman ticos y estudiando la pasión
y determinación
y para estimar el ámbito de la
investigación científica fue ampliando
comprenderlos y discriminación para las
jóvenes y las mujeres en la ciencia y el
último está afortunado ver como menos el
30 por ciento de los emisores son
mujeres por lo tanto creo que el mayor
reto es comprender y así como ser mujer
científica
ciencia
cualquiera
porque usted es un niño para aprender a
no decir las puertas tienen la
oportunidad
de hacer las preguntas porque los mismos
científicos y porque sus preguntas en
vez en sus cabezas con burbujas y una
tras otra perceptual las cosas porque
los niños no le temen equivocarse
y se los digo
[Música]
aquí
es momento de presentar a la universidad
la carrera
porque le dan ganas de aprender
[Música]
el estudio científico y sigue bajando
calidad
[Música]
pero mi trabajo
valor de compromiso
cuando el mundo bailando la secundaria
que desean muchas veces en sus
familiares de ganas y de ventas es que
me lo decían que le preguntaba una
profecía y casualmente le ganas
es el esfuerzo más
el maestro dos académicos una estrella
capaz de hacer pero que antes de darse
todo lo he hecho siempre tuve buenas
teniendo segundos de miedo a nuestra
posición de una competencia proyecto
usarlo porque este nido es parte de
nuestra vida es esencial lo que esos
consumidores eligen entre las armas
todos los días
si tenemos preguntas eran personas con
proyectos pues vacilantes pero es porque
estás haciendo no vas a cantar y sin
miedo al azar tus venas
y yo les digo esto porque siempre ser
una persona que nos haga realidad
[Música]
corriendo
es una persona que apoya a la naturaleza
es decir como idioma hermoso y
extraordinario
porque la decisión una persona compartía
dificultad auditiva visual motora
sensorial múltiple es una suele estar de
un año para celular todo lo que suponga
están antes que las cosas para amparar
es así como de proyectos de acciones
sino para siempre mis maestros lastre
una enorme pasión fue la ciencia por la
situación este y en estos puntos que nos
estaba hablando
espero que dieron a tales tribunal
porque él para que el vídeo que está
haciendo para mejorar y transformar tu
vida tu comunidad tu sociedad y tu mundo
porque yo las personas que vivían
pláticas conferencias charlas talleres
de personas productos increíbles pues no
es las charlas actual a impactar a tomar
malas para ser diferente para
completamente esfuerzas conocido y la
mente para atreverme es el final del
largo camino todos los demás
existe innovando y creando transformar
de verdad es increíble puedes cobrar
cuatro copias del disco así si tienes
una meta un sueño un proyecto simple
medias de muestra puede hacer y después
cambiar las demás sólo mantenemos los
sueños que podríamos adversaria muchas
gracias
[Música]